[Musique]
je suis mohamed el bachiri belgo
marocain musulman molenbeekois avec se
traînant ses convictions religieuse et
la réputation de la commune dans
laquelle je vis je suis considéré par
une partie de la population et du monde
comme un terroriste potentiel et cela
m'affecte beaucoup je suis également
l'époux de loubna l'afld qui rit l'amour
de ma vie mon ami la mère de mes enfants
décédés lors des attentats du 22 mars
2016 à bruxelles
loubna femme à la beauté inégalable et à
la bonté infinie
ce regard posé sur moi son sourire sa
présence faisait de moi le plus beau le
plus fortuné le plus comblé de tous les
hommes aujourd'hui notre tristesse est
incommensurable et si je suis debout
ce n'est que grâce et par l'amour par
l'amour que je porte à mon épouse
l'amour pour mes enfants
l'amour pour la vie et l'amour pour
l'humanité
amour qui m'a incité à appeler au jihad
lors d'une soirée organisée dans une
église ou musulmans chrétiens et autres
avions partagé un repas dans un esprit
de fraternité oui j'ai appelé au jihad
mais attention pas n'importe quel jade
je parle de ce dialogue qui ne connaît
pas la haine car la haine est un pesant
fardeau qui noircit les coeurs je parle
du vrai du plus noble du plus grand
combat des musulmans contre la terreur
ce jihad qui incite à aller vers les
autres
son frère différents pour lui sourire
pour le comprendre et lui exprimer de
l'empathie ce jihad qui aime qui a
besoin d'aimer pour exister qui cherche
l'étreinte pour éteindre les flammes de
la rancoeur et qui en aucun cas n'impose
sa vérité car comme il est dit dans le
coran l'un est que la rapide dean nulle
contrainte en religion
ce jihad mondial
cri d'amour pour l'occident
cette partie du monde qui m'a vu naître
et qui m'a tant donné
moi l'enfant de l'univers votre frère en
humanité et ce jihad devrait être la
réponse des musulmans à ceux qui
cherchent à nous diviser et à propager
la violence et la terreur comme si dans
un champ de bataille le cri agonisant
des vaincus et est une symphonie à la
gloire du dieu victorieux maudite soit
la guerre
maudit soit le terrorisme je reviens
l'essentiel l'amour ce socle sur lequel
toute pensée toute croyance tout être
humain devrait se reposer
elle devrait à la fois être une force
universelle est la base de toute
communication entre nous les êtres
humains dans cette relation axé sur
l'amour nul la prétention de détenir la
vérité vraie et encore moins la volonté
de l'imposer cette quête de vérité
nous l'avons à chacun de nous sait
une des caractéristiques de l'animal
raisonnable que nous sommes
pour ma part le chemin emprunté et
l'islam et ce chemin là est empruntée
dans le but d'aller vers ce que les
grecs appelaient l'ataraxie l'apaisement
de l'âme c'est ce que je souhaite à
chacun d'entre nous le chemin emprunté
pour ma part et l'islam mais ce chemin
est empruntée parce que je suis dans un
premier temps un être humain d'où de
manière logique l'importance de mettre
en avant mon humanité
avant mon islamité mon humanité avec
toutes les valeurs humanistes que cela
comporte
à savoir la sacralité de la vie humaine
le libre arbitre et le rapport fraternel
entre tous les êtres humains être
humaniste musulmans c'est accepter
savourer est considéré comme un
privilège
le fait de vivre dans la diversité
c'est aussi la capacité de
contextualiser les textes du coran
notamment les passages guerriers et les
considérer comme des récits historiques
propres 7e siècle qui ne peuvent en
aucun cas être utilisé pour faire du mal
ou ôté la vie à autrui être humaniste
musulmans c'est s'intéresser à notre
histoire commune celle de l'humanité
avec tous ces grands hommes qui ont fait
avancer le monde
ces hommes de la grèce antique de
mésopotamie de rome de chine d'occident
et d'orient s'est arrêté un moment de
regarder vers les cieux et se tourner
vers son prochain pour lui sourire et le
comprendre et si mon prochain est à
l'antipode de ce que je pense de ce que
je crois c'est pas grave car comme
disait héraclite
il y avait ri té dans une chose et dans
son contraire pour ma part moi meme je
sui contradictions partagé entre raison
et mysticisme conviction et scepticisme
mais toujours et jusqu'au dernier
souffle
porté par l'amour en ces temps
difficiles et incertains
j'appelle au dialogue et à l'échangé est
plutôt que de s'attarder sur la haine et
la folie des saints
tournons nous vers le génie et la bonté
de l'humanité car c'est et cela restera
la source d'inspiration et d'espoir pour
ceux à qui nous empruntons la terre nos
enfants je soulignerai aussi
l'importance de la culture car c'est ce
qui mène à l'ouverture et quand je vois
averroès ce philosophe musulman qui a
traduit qui a permis la traduction de
nombreux textes grecs et commentés
également de nombreux textes grecs et a
permis la transmission par conséquent
permet la transmission de la majeure
partie de la pensée aristotélicienne à
l'occident ce qui nous ce qui a
contribué quelque part à la renaissance
quand je le vois immortalisé au palais
du vatican dans une fresque de parler
main de rafael
je ne peut que ressentir une grande
émotion et constater que nous musulmans
pouvons et avant déjà auparavant
contribué à la grandeur de l'occident et
de l'humanité et que finalement il n'y a
pas de choc de civilisations mais deux
magnifiques rencontres
j'aimerais conclure et terminer par un
texte que j'ai écrit peu après la
disparition de mon épouse
c'était pour moi une réponse à ceux qui
ont détruit ma vie et mon bonheur
ce texte intitulé allah akbar je pense
que c'est le cas de la plupart des
musulmans allah ouakbar doux murmure
provenant du coeur qu'on ne peut
entendre mais tellement plus vrai que
celui utilisé pour détruire
i'm a mac val pour l'amour que je porte
au plat pays qui est le mien et au
royaume chérifien à la wac balle pour la
beauté pour l'art pour cette oeuvre qui
dégage une émotion si forte qu'elle
ferait fondre en larmes
le plus glacial des coeurs à la havane
cuba pour cette diversité pour ses
cultures ses croyances ses gens avec
lesquels on discute on échange et on
accepte que finalement chacun détient sa
vérité dans un esprit de fraternité à la
barbade lorsqu on réprouve la violence
et qu'on ouvre pour la paix et l'amitié
entre les peuples a mouse balles lorsque
je souris et je tends la main à toi le
juif
là t'es où le chrétien allahou akbar
pour ceux qui ont compris que dieu est
amour et que le salut de l'homme ne
viendra qu'à travers cette force
universelle exprimé pour son prochain à
marwijk van doos pensées et prières pour
toi loubna mon amour et pour toutes les
victimes qui vivront à jamais dans nos
coeurs et dans nos mémoires je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]